Deadpool didn't just shake up the status quo
for action adventures starring guys in capes
it went the extra mile and set a lot of cinematic
precedents, some of them quite subtly. if
you can believe it.
This is how Deadpool changed movies and you
barely noticed.
Deadpool's marketing is basically a movie's
worth of entertainment in and of itself.
Seriously, from Mother's Day gags to billboards
that shouldn't exist, the folks behind Deadpool
pulled out all the stops to make sure hype
would be at its absolute peak by the time
the superhero hit the big screen.
What made it so special isn't just its excessive,
over-the-top humor, but also its not-so-subtle
meta slant.
Befitting the character, Deadpool's marketing
made sure to tap into fourth-wall-breaking
territory, showcasing a degree of self-awareness
that elated the meme generation.
"You're probably thinking, 'My boyfriend said
this was a superhero movie.'
Well, surprise: This is actually lucky you
a love story."
This movie knew its target demographic so
well that it transcended its own status, resulting
in Deadpool's pre-release antics being shared
as entertainment rather than advertising.
This led to an unprecedented degree of organic
word of mouth, which likely played a huge
part in Deadpool's debut as the one of the
biggest R-rated openings of all time.
So what if Justice League has A-listers like
The Flash, Aquaman, and Wonder Woman?
No one cares about them or that movie; B-listers
are the new hot property.
After all, Deadpool was only as good as its
red-suited merc and his ensemble of backup
dancers, which included beloved comic book
characters like… uhh hang on, let us check
our notes Weasel… and Negasonic Teenage
Warhead…
"Negasonic teenage — what the s---?!
That's the coolest name EVER!"
Okay, yeah, neither of these were fan favorites.
And while Colossus definitely has a following,
it'd be a serious stretch to call him an A-lister.
Really, the cast of this movie, from top to
bottom, was as B-list or below as it got and
that's probably why it worked so well.
Virtually none of these characters had to
worry about living up to overwhelming audience
expectations, meaning there was minimal pressure
and maximum freedom to adapt them however
would best suit the film.
And that's exactly what Deadpool did, writing
them smartly and entertainingly enough to
fit within the film's universe while simultaneously
maintaining their core comic book identities.
For those reasons, the movie nailed building
its own team of budget Avengers, effectively
proving to Hollywood that you don't need an
Iron Man or Wonder Woman to produce a moneymaker
loaded with franchise-starting characters.
"It's a big house.
It's funny that I only ever see two of you.
It's almost like… the studio couldn't afford
another X-man."
If there's one movie that shines as a prime
example of what fans can accomplish when they
band together to create buzz on the internet,
it's Deadpool.
If not for the leaked test footage, we might
very well have never gotten a Deadpool solo
movie at all.
But Fox felt compelled to dish out $58 million
which isn't even all that much in superhero
movie money as a result of a lot of geeks
on the internet screaming about how much they
wanted some goofball in a red jumpsuit to
shoot people and say bad words.
What a time we live in.
"We all sort of said at the beginning, 'Someone
should leak it!
Someone should leak it.'
So (???) the idea was (???) But I'm 70% sure
it wasn't me."
Though we've yet to see another brave test
footage leaker come out of the woodwork to
make their hypothetical dream movie a studio-budgeted
reality, it doesn't change the fact that the
Deadpool situation and the response by Fox
set a new precedent in the filmmaking world:
when the internet speaks, it can make real
change.
In the old days, Hollywood was a gated kingdom
where the true power brokers all wore suits
and traded business cards.
Moving forward, we now know another party
has a voice at the decision-making table:
the fans.
It's just a matter of making enough noise.
A lot of films fall into the trap of being
overly sincere or, in more recent years, too
self-aware.
Movies like Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
showed us what can happen when a movie takes
itself far too seriously.
On the other end of the spectrum, if every
other minute of a film is littered with self-referential
dialogue, then there's no room whatsoever
for real emotional investment by the audience.
Deadpool, the first and best of its meta-kind,
showed that it's possible to be extremely
self-aware but also legitimately emotional
at the same time.
Deadpool tied most of its fourth-wall-breaking
antics to the main character's superhero alter
ego, so that whenever Wade and Vanessa were
sharing an intimate, real beat, no cynical,
self-deprecating humor would crop up and ruin
the moment.
"Your life is officially waaay more f---ed
up than mine."
"I love you."
It was a smart balancing move that ensured
audiences would care about Wade and Vanessa's
happiness and well-being, while also being
able to laugh at all of Deadpool's zany shenanigans.
Prior to Deadpool, few thought that a movie
loaded with CGI gunfights, throwdowns, and
explosions could ever operate as a functional
comedy.
Guardians of the Galaxy was as close as any
superhero film had come to achieving that,
and even that movie veered more into action-adventure
territory.
Deadpool went for the guffaws right from its
opening title sequence all the way 'til the
very end of its credits.
For the crowds who like raunchy Seth Rogen
comedies and Seth MacFarlane's comedic fare,
this movie fit the bill and felt more like
a Marvel-flavored big-budget parody than an
actual superhero movie.
Deadpool's effects on the industry are readily
apparent.
It might've come out later that same year,
but given the extensive reshoots Suicide Squad
went through, one can venture a guess that
the movie's sudden influx of meta-humor might've
been the result of Deadpool's success.
And just look at Shazam!, another keenly self-aware
superhero movie that, unlike its DCEU contemporaries,
is actually, well… fun.
Who's to say what kind of tone it would've
aimed for without Deadpool to prove that a
superhero movie doesn't have to be such a
brooding, mopey affair?
"Do you like what you see?"
"No.
You look like an avacado had sex with an older,
more disgusting avacado."
"Yeah."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.